okay. I have a clip for you today that is
notable not only for its absurdity and it's
stupidity as much as it's notable for its
truly Zena phobic basis. When you listen to
what it is that Tucker Carlson said on his
show the other day, um, in dismissing the
idea that Russia interfered in the 2016 election,
even though they did, even though the Mueller
report makes that clear, even though our intelligence
agencies all found that Russia interfered,
Tucker Carlson did something sort of slick,
I'll admit it, sort of slick, sort of ignorant
and it's very zenith phobic, but it is a little
bit slick. He said that the real election
interference is Mexican people who legally
became citizens of the United States and then
voted as is their right of citizenship. It's
as ridiculous as it sounds. I'm going to play
a clip for you were Tucker Carlson is apparently
arguing that everything Russia did for which
we have endless evidence is not interference
in an election, but that Mexican people who
come here legally become citizens and then
choose to vote is a form of interference.
Now you've got to listen really carefully
to the words that are used and what Tucker
Carlson says here, take a look. Well, if you
watch Robert Mueller
speak this morning and 11 you heard him echo
the view of official Washington that Russia
had a major effect on the 2016 election. Well,
as we've noted before, that is an absurd claim.
There is zero evidence that it's true. None
that Robert Mueller himself has presented,
but if you're looking for countries that really
do influence American politics, there are
quite a few. Anyone who lives in DC can tell
you that Russia does not make the list. Mexico
definitely does. At the beginning of the past
presidential election cycle, for example,
Mexico began what Bloomberg News described
as an unprecedented effort to get American
citizenship for its permanent residents living
here in the u s the point was obvious of course,
to make them voters so they could vote to
defeat Donald Trump, Russia ever even considered
election hacking. That bold
Tucker is suggesting here that Mexicans who
meet the requirements to become citizens and
become citizens and then choose to vote are
committing a type of interference in the election.
That is actually interference. Unlike what
Russia did in 2016 number one, citizens voting
is not interference in until election. It's
called the election process. Right? When people
are citizens and they vote, that is not a
way to interfere with the election. It is
a way to participate in the election. The
definition of interference is the action of
interfering or the process of being interfered
with. When American citizens vote, it's not
interfering with the election process. It's
the election process. When Russia metals accesses
voting systems helps one candidate get dirt
on another runs, social media campaigns and
trolling campaigns and fake news campaigns
and disinformation campaigns online. That
is not a main election process. Those are
our actions that are interfering with the
election.
When you get beyond that, you realize that
this is fundamentally Zena phobic because
the underlying motivation or implication here
is that, well, yeah, of course citizens get
to vote here, but when it's Brown people from
Mexico who obtained citizenship through naturalization,
it's not really part of the democratic process.
It's an interference with the democratic process.
Now from a logistical standpoint, can you
imagine this as a strategy to affect the election
results by Mexico? You're counting on people
from Mexico coming to the United States legally
living here long enough to qualify to apply
for citizenship, applying for citizenship,
paying all of the associated costs, eventually
getting that citizenship all to vote in elections
legally as a means to affect elections. It
would be an incredibly stupid and inefficient
way to try to affect the election results
in the United States, and if you believe that,
you would probably believe the idea as many
Trumpettes do, that Barack Obama was part
of a conspiracy that dates back to his birth
to get a foreigner, to be president of the
United States, some kind of shadow.
We entity that, I guess 45 years before Barack
Obama became president, fake the birth certificate
to make sure that a foreign born dude would
be president in 2008 in the United States.
They faked his parents. They fake the birth
certificate. Who knows what the latest version
of that conspiracy is. If you believe that,
then I guess maybe you would believe that
Mexicans having the longterm plan of becoming
legal citizens in order to vote is a way to
interfere and affect elections. Any normal,
sensible, rational person would realize the
absurdity of it. And as part of this kind
of long game idea, you don't actually need
to go to that Mexican conspiracy to understand
the long game that Russia has been playing.
I mean, go back to the 1997 book foundations
of, of geopolitics by Aleksandr Dugin. And
you will see that everything Russia has been
doing in the United States and elsewhere for
the last several years was written out and
suggested as a strategy for sewing geopolitical
chaos to Russia's advantage more than 20 years
ago in the book foundations of geopolitics.
But listen, this is, if you are in Tucker
Carlson's core Fox News audience, you probably
hear this idea of Mexicans are interfering
by legally becoming citizens and voting. Uh,
it's probably a great fit for you. And it's
probably the type of stuff that makes Tucker
Carlson have those solid ratings on Fox News.
Disgusting, absolutely disgusting. But I understand
why Tucker Carlson saying it because this
audience is eating it up like it's being spoonfed
to them